it's a move that's rekindling the debate
over the future of spain's catalonia
region and its independence movement
the results of the voting session of
monday the 8th of march
the european parliament has removed the
immunity of khalis pujdemont
former catalan president and two
associates all of whom have seats in the
assembly
they fled abroad in 2017 following an
independence referendum
and subsequent declaration of
independence which the spanish
government deemed illegal
it is a sad day for european parliament
we have lost our immunity
but the european parliament has lost
more than that
and as a result european democracy too
this is a clear case of political
persecution
the decision could help madrid's bid to
extradite the trio
carla's pujdamon tony comey and carla
poncetti have been charged with sedition
in spain
quiddimont and comey are also accused of
misusing public funds
but poncetti who's based in scotland
told al jazeera they're confident of
winning an appeal
we will contest this lifting of immunity
in the european court of justice because
our claim is that this is a political
prosecution and as such
our immunity should not have been lifted
that will take some time but we have
very strong arguments and very strong
hopes
that we will prevail on this appeal
the 2017 independence referendum stoked
major tensions between the spanish
government
and the leaders of catalonia an
autonomous region of seven and a half
million people
the bitterness of the debate has
diminished since socialist prime
minister pedro sanchez came to power in
madrid in 2018.
but in last month's regional elections
separatist parties gained four
additional seats in the catalan
parliament
the independent is parties who come from
the
right to the center to the left so there
are all kinds of
uh political opinions in the independent
these parties
they want this majority in the catalan
parliament so this proves that we still
have the
the elephant in the room meanwhile a
belgian court recently rejected spain's
request to extradite another former
catalan cabinet member
and it's far from clear how authorities
here and in scotland
will cooperate with madrid now nadine
barber al jazeera